the world teaches us that long hours are
inevitable and inescapable that overwork
is a badge of honor and resting is a
weakness super successful people rise
and grind are always on and never stop
deep down we know this is unhealthy and
unsustainable but is there an
[Music]
alternative downtime is deeply
undervalued in today's 247 world but it
hasn't always been this way virtually
every ancient Society defined the good
life as balancing work and rest and
Recent research in neuroscience and
psychology has shown that rest
strengthens our brains enhances our
learning and stimulates our creativity
history's most accomplished scientists
writers and military leaders worked far
fewer hours than we do today and built
daily routines full of downtime people
like naturalist Charles Darwin and
geneticist Barbara mclintoch who both
took daily walks knew that work and rest
are are not opposites they are Partners
you won't fully flourish until you can
Master both here's where you can start
first rethink what rest is getting
enough sleep at night is key and
20-minute naps are wonderful for a boost
but when it comes to taking downtime in
the day the most restorative rest isn't
found on a couch or in front of a screen
the best rest is active exercise Hobbies
walks these recharge our mental and
physical batteries more effectively and
get give us more stamina and resilience
than being a couch potato rest is
natural but it's also a skill it's
something we can practice and improve
over time just as athletes singers and
Buddhist monks use breathing to run
faster project their voices and calm
their minds we can use rest to boost our
creativity and Recovery second integrate
it into your daily work athletes get the
best results combining intensive
training and Recovery likewise
creative people should layer periods of
distraction-free deep work with periods
of deliberate rest so design a routine
that lets you focus and get into flow
for four or 5 hours a day every day make
those periods more intensive not longer
by killing distractions give yourself
permission to turn off email and
messages and concentrate on what matters
and then if you have the flexibility
give yourself a nice long active break
it will give your creat subconscious a
chance to work on unsolved problems
while you recover and generate those
insights and aha moments that turn good
ideas into breakthroughs and if you
don't have that flexibility find a way
to make sure that when you're off from
work that you apply these same
principles to at least part of your
downtown third tap into deep play
Creative passionate people need breaks
from their work but those breaks have to
be just as compelling as their work or
they won't take them many scientist and
CEOs or amateur painters musicians or
chefs on the side these are hobbies that
provide the same sense of accomplishment
control Mastery and flow that they get
when work goes really well but in a
different environment and with a clear
quick reward often their interests which
date from childhood which makes them
even more meaningful so Embrace an
activity that makes you feel alive and
involved in the world it's not a
distraction it'll give you new
experiences and the same pleasures and
rewards as work at its best without the
compromises or ambiguities that often
Cloud things fourth make rest social the
Working World Isn't designed for rest we
have to take it and one of the most
powerful ways to guarantee that we make
time for rest is to do it with others so
start work early and meet a colleague
for a walk in the afternoon or team up
with your partner to perform a tea
ceremony or make a childcare swapping
arrang with a friend to give you both
more time for rest remember it's not
easy for busy highly driven people to
rest it requires developing new
practices and giving them time to become
habits you can't rush it just as it
takes time to settle into a new job or
home your mind needs time to start
harnessing the power of rest don't beat
yourself up if you aren't already doing
anything like this there's no better
time to start than
now